Yeah,
it's like a muscle twitch go. You'd go,
just see how far you can make it happen.
Horse. So you start talking and
then being an agent and a foot race,
put your money where your mouth,
this asshole.
You just see eyes widen and they're
like, yeah, you're like, dude,
we're not at a seminar right now.
That's what's bullshit about seminars.
I mean came back and if you were
in the world of business, see,
I really think this is one of the reasons
why so many people are so fucked up
and so depressed.
I think the world of showing to showing
up to a place and then having your
behavior limited into this very narrow
and rigid parameters all day long and
your livelihood and your success of your,
your family and whether or not you
can send your kids to a good school.
All that dependent upon whether or
not you're willing to play the rules,
you have to wear an outfit with a
suit and tie because if you don't,
you might be unpredictable and
you show up with that t shirt on.
He's got a foot pole shirt on at work.
What the fuck is he drunk?
What is he going crazy? He's
doing drugs. You can't true
join around people that don't just
light joins around people. You like the
Steckler.
I crashed Tesla's stock by $9 billion.
Shit. So crazy. Yeah, but not
really. It bounced right back.
Is that world like the guy can't? First
of all, we were drinking whisky. Okay.
No one has a problem with that,
which is way more of a hard drug.
Way more of a crazy drug. Then a little
puff of a joint. We were drinking whiskey.
No one cared. We drank whiskey
for three hours. No one cared.
Smoked a little joint. Oh, you think
he inhaled it? Didn't look like it.
Then look away and just took like a
ninth grader. He didn't know what to do.
He took a little puff, you know? Yeah.
New Kid at school just needs, everyone
just wants to, oh, I do it too.
No bad. Yeah. Fascinating.
Yeah, it was crazy.
He did it and I mean another layer of
it. He did it in California. Exactly.
Totally, totally legal. Yeah. Yeah.
It's no different than having
that class with whiskey. You know,
California said he could fly
with it. Now what? Lex said,
you could have an ounce of weed
with you on an airplane. They said,
we don't know what the fuck's going to
happen when you land somewhere where you
can go through lax with an ounce
of weed. I'm sorry. By the way,
I looked up private suite after
I talked to you. Super expensive.
So expensive, stupid, expensive. How
did you know about it? Uh, Sam Harris.
He told me about it.
Yeah.